whoa whoa
see that guy right there looks like he's
hit rock bottom
well that guy's actually meat believe it
or not now I bet you're wondering how I
got in this biking situation it all
started in the summer these my name is
PewDiePie I am one of the smartest
intellectuals on this planet my IQ is at
least 5,000 oh don't believe me
I've watched at least at least three and
a half episodes of Rick and Marty the
pregnant edition one time I thought
about reading half a book and my
favorite hobby of all time is beating my
own meat I mean reading philosophy while
beating my my fellow intellectuals yes I
am talking about you although you're not
just quite as brilliant as me we have
gathered here today to celebrate some of
the finest intellectuals on the planet
some of the smartest people some of the
people that just puts humanity to the
top to the top here we have how many
presidents from United States an average
u.s. citizen no I am from Europe and I
know 25 of them ha ha I have had IRL sex
many times when you are 6 to strongly
backed in have an IQ of 1
one it is difficult to live the track
life even the waves even though I even
though I wish I did something sometimes
I wish I would live down here with you
nor me peasants just so I could have an
average life because I am just having so
many of the sexes just downvote there is
no way you can win a debate against me
[Music]
Shh
whoa whoa see that guy right there looks
like he said rock-bottom
what what is bot not a real world not a
real word as far as I'm able to
recognize is it the same as you
instead of proper a form of our alien
Newspeak like internet slang degenerates
yours ah the horrible dystopia we live
in but people use shortage of you into
the lot of you what is next
if people are gonna say they're chilling
and relaxing they're gonna start saying
she'll axing we truly live in a
nightmarish world are you ever about to
drop a sarcastic comment but then you
decide against it because they're small
brains won't understand your elite humor
yes yes preach this is me all the time
when I make jokes for YouTube I'm sorry
I don't know who Skrillex is I was busy
listening to path hoppin Chekhov's and
other various classical artists that I
forgot to go bumbling through YouTube
look for whatever that is sidenote
Skrillex seriously just sounds like a
bunch of random computer-generated
annoying noises to me I'll stick to my
piano and violin hah
juster my brain too complex for your
Skrillex
- Debbie Greta you can select my baby or
Nana
oh yeah
well you still look like a chipmunk boom
no wait oh yeah well you you look like a
wombat who's who's the smart one now
Nigeria grad student uses magnets to
prove gay marriage is wrong you know
what I had my suspicions it was all
about the magnets I you know I told my
friend the other day actually you know
what I bet there is a correlation
between the magnets and the gay marriage
being wrong I just don't have time to
look into that study right now as I am
busy as I am busy on my other married
people mark the Bible because of things
like unicorns now science says they're
real and no one mocks huh do some
research if you don't understand what I
said you know what my liberal if you
don't understand the incoherent babbling
that I'm spewing then you're not eat
election winner don't even bother me if
you're not a cute level then don't even
speak to me or anyone I know rice gum
yeah me see you later alligator her why
alligator
me alligators can live up to 100 years
which is why there's an increased chance
that they will see you later
oh my god I can't believe Rice CIM is an
intellectual just like myself I always
thought this guy was just an idiot Wow
how wrong how wrong it was my pardon mr.
Roskam you are correct your thesis about
the alligators of course how could we
have been so blind well what the [ __ ]
what is this
well this is a pretty private here he
has risen beyond the mental capacity of
an average person you speak so formally
it annoys me once again I apologize I
suppose you simply cannot comprehend the
intellect with which I speak now this is
not a down play on your end but simply
shows have written far beyond the mental
capacity of of the average human I feel
like that could have just been a troll
comment I don't know or an actually
intellectual wish of course everyone
that watch my channel is it's a real
common you know what being a history
nerd it's a bit of a killjoy because a
lot of things stop being funny for
example I can't even watch paka hunters
anymore without gritting my teeth and
it's sad because it's an awesome no in
the history by Pocahontas doesn't mean
you're a history nerd where are all
those women hiding I never met a female
that could be even half of my mental
ability the vast majority of them are
average intelligence at best at best
which is absolutely stupid s/f compared
to me I could seriously drink 30 shots
of vodka and still be far more
Cape why have I not found a woman ah my
stupid brain why do I have to be so
smart stopping me from getting all these
[ __ ] Happy New Year thanks but I don't
celebrate New Year's people like me are
cognizant of the passing of time on a
daily if not a continuous basis hence I
have no need for such a holiday I feel
like this is you Brad come on Brad
doesn't celebrate his birthday or
anything like that
and any time I ride him he wrote he
writes exactly that response it's true
yes
my man Neil deGrasse Tyson a true
intellectual sometimes I wonder if we'd
have flying cars by now had civilization
spent a little less brain energy
contemplating football I don't like
sports you don't need your brain for
sports
we could have playing cards by now I'm
about to transform any minute
[Applause]
[Applause]